a quoi là on va aller tout de suite sur
ces images en direct à Washington du
président
ukrainien volodimear Zelenski qui salue
vous le voyez la vice-présidente
américaine Kamala Harris salut à nouveau
Nancy Pelosi avec laquelle il s'est
entre nous entretenu un peu plus tôt
voilà des Mira Zelenski devant
le Congrès américain on l'écoute
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
bonjour
de vous présenter son Excellence voilà
de mer vous annoncer président de
l'Ukraine
merci beaucoup
merci c'est trop pour moi
tout ça
pour notre peuple magnifique merci
beaucoup
les Américains
tous ceux qui partagent une valeur à la
liberté à la justice
autant que nous les Ukrainiens dans nos
villes
dans chaque famille j'espère que mes
paroles de respect et de gratitude
résonne dans le cœur de chaque Américain
vice-présidente
je vous remercie de vos efforts
de votre aide pour madame la présidente
de la Chambre de représentants vous avez
très courageusement visiter l'Ukraine
pendant la guerre en pleine essor merci
beaucoup c'était une vraie honneur pour
nous
représentant des deux parties qui ont
également rendu visite qui est
estimé congrès membre du Congrès du
Canada de deux parties qui vont visiter
l'Ukraine à l'avenir
des représentés de la spirale
de diaspora
[Applaudissements]
et les journalistes c'est un honneur
pour moi d'être devant le Congrès
américain et de vous adresser et à tous
les Américains
contre toute attente
et les jours sinistres
l'Ukraine n'est pas tombé l'Ukraine est
vivante
l'Ukraine est vivante
merci
ce qui me donne une bonne raison de
partager avec vous
notre première victoire on a battu la
Russie dans
les réflexions du monde entier nous
n'avons aucune peur et ni devrait
personne avoir la peur dans le monde
lucane a gagné cette victoire et ça nous
donne le courage
c'est courage qui aspire le monde entier
deuxième américain ont gagné cette
victoire et c'est pour cela que vous
avez réussi pour unir tous les critiques
globale pour protéger la liberté et le
droit international des Européens ont
aussi gagné cette victoire et c'est pour
cela que l'Europe est maintenant
renforcée et plus indépendant que jamais
le tyrannie de la Russie a perdu le
contrôle sur nous
[Applaudissements]
et ils vont plus jamais influer sur
notre esprit mais il faut faire ce qu'il
faut pour s'assurer
je sais
encore une chose du Grand d'importance
c'est que les Russes vont avoir une
possibilité d'être libre seulement
lorsque ils vont battre le Kremlin dans
leur tête
pourtant de bataille continue et nous
devons battre le Kremlin sur le champ de
bataille oui cette bataille c'est pas
seulement pour le territoire
ça fait partie de l'Europe ce n'est pas
seulement pour la vie mais la sécurité
et la liberté des Ukrainiens et tout
autre nation que la Russie tente de
concourir cette lutte va définir dans
quel monde nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants vont évoluer et vivre et
leurs enfants et leurs petits-enfants
Apprieu définiront si ce sera la
démocratie en Ukraine et pour les
Américains et pour tous
cette bataille ne peut pas être gelée ni
remise à plus tard ça ne peut pas être
ignoré
dans l'espoir que l'océan ou quelque
chose d'autre va fournir une protection
quelconque
et la Chine en Europe ou à l'Amérique
latine et de l'Afrique en Australie le
monde
est trop intellcté et interdépendant
pour permettre à quelqu'un
d'affirmer et de se sentir sécurisé dans
d'avoir initié une telle bataille sa
bataille continue une deux nations
sont hélas dans son engagés dans cette
bataille et l'année prochaine sera le
point tournant je le sais c'est le point
où le courage ukrainien et les rougeurs
américains doivent garantir l'avenir de
nos libertés à nous tous des gens qui
dépend défendent leurs valeurs
[Applaudissements]
avant de venir ici
j'étais sur la ligne du front
à
notre fort au nord dans le Dombasle
les militaires russes
jour et nuit le bac restent toujours
acquis
malgré leur défense de cette position
l'année dernière
70 000 personnes vivaient là à Batman
dans cette ville et maintenant il reste
que quelques civils chaque centimètre de
cette terre est trempé en sens every
hour on entend les les les
artillerie toutes les heures plusieurs
fois par jour il y a des combats
acharnés et même de combat de la main à
la main mais dans basse tiens
et lui
tiens
les Russes
utilise tout ce qui peuvent
contre batmotte
et notre Hainaut belle ville ailleurs
les occupants en avantage significatif
dans l'artillerie ils ont davantage dans
les munitions ils ont beaucoup plus de
missiles et d'avions que nous n'avons
jamais eu c'est vrai mais notre défense
et nos forces de défense tiennent
toujours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sommes tous fiers de
tactique de russe c'est primitive
il brûle et détruisent tout ce qu'il
voit ils envoient
des
félons à la guerre ils ont tout balancé
contre nous similaire aux autres
tyrannies dans la bataille du belge
ils ont envoyé tout contre le mur comme
le soldat américain courageux qui ont
tenu le fond du tu quand les forces
d'Hitler à Noël de 1944 des Ukrainiens
courageux font la même chose aujourd'hui
face aux forces de footing pendant ce
Noël
les graines
tiens
le front et ne va jamais lâcher
de se rendre à jamais
[Applaudissements]
donc ici sur le front la tyrannie
qui ne manque pas du cruauté contre la
vie des gens libres et votre soutien est
crucial pas seulement pour se tenir dans
la bataille mais pour arriver au point
tournant pour gagner sur le champ de
bataille nous avons la Thierry oui et
merci
nous l'avons est-ce que c'est suffisant
honnêtement pas vraiment
pour s'assurer
que bague mode ne soit pas juste un fort
pour contenir l'effort heureuses mais
pour que les l'armée russe se retirent
complètement
et pour cela il faut plus de canon et de
c'est comme le caractère de sératoga
dans la lutte au bac mood va changer la
face et le trajectoire de notre guerre
vers l'indépendance et vers la liberté
si vous patriotes
[Musique]
contre nos villes ça permettra aux
Ukrainiens travailler pleinement pour
défendre notre liberté
[Applaudissements]
lorsque la Russie ne peut pas atteindre
nos villes avec son Algérie ils décident
de détruire nos villes avec des missiles
plus encore ils ont trouvé un allié dans
cet effort dans cette politique
génocidale c'est l'Iran
par des centaines sur
Ukraine c'est une menace nos
infrastructures critiques
c'est ça comme ça qu'un terroriste a
trouvé une autre terroriste c'est juste
une question de temps ils vont encore
frapper contre vos autres alliés si on
ne les arrête pas maintenant il faut le
faire
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'il y a pas de tabou
dans notre alliance
l'Ukraine n'a jamais demandé le soldat
américain de lutter sur le terrain au
lieu de nous je vous assure que le
soldat ukrainien peuvent parfaitement
opérer les blindés américains
[Musique]
et les avions ils peuvent les opérer
eux-mêmes
[Applaudissements]
l'assistance financière est aussi d'une
cape importance capitale je veux vous
remercier énormément
pour les packages financiers que vous
avez déjà fournis
ce que vous allez peut-être sur lequel
vous avez décédé ce n'est pas de la
charité c'est un investissement dans la
sécurité globale et les démocraties
quand j'ai de la manière la plus
responsable qui soit
la Russie
vraiment
s'il voulait
mais vous pouvez accélérer notre
victoire je le sais
[Applaudissements]
et ça prouvera à n'importe quel
agresseur potentiel que personne ne peut
réussir à casser les frontières
nationales personne qui commet d'être
cités tel et et
d'attendre des pieds que s'affranchi le
pas pour aller vers la paix
ils sont toujours empoisonnés par les
Kremlin
la restauration de l'ordre légal
juridique c'est une tâche conjointe on a
besoin de paix oui l'Ukraine a déjà
proposé la paix
comme je viens de l'évoquer le berger
lombardin
évidemment il y a 10 points pour le
sécurité conjointe il faut ce qu'elle
soit garantie pour le dessiner à venir
et le sommet qui peut être tenu je suis
ravi de savoir que le président Baden a
soutenu notre initiative vers la paix
aujourd'hui chacun d'entre vous peut
assister dans la mise en place pour
s'assurer que je peux américain reste
solide
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez renforcer les sanctions pour
que la Russie sente à quel point ces
ruineux pour eux de poursuivre c'est
dans votre pouvoir vraiment de nous
aider à emmener les gens à justice tous
ceux qui ont commencé cette guerre non
provoquée et criminel il faisons mieux
punitions les terroristes
[Applaudissements]
et qu'il compense toutes les pertes
provoquées par ces guerres que la guerre
voit que les États-Unis sont là qu'ils
le sachent
monsieur dame
monsieur
américain en deux jours
nous allons
fêter Noël
peut-être la bougie
pas parce que c'est plus romantique non
parce que
il y aura pas d'électricité
des millions non ni chauffage ni au
courant
tout cela est le résultat des missiles
et des drones des attaques sur notre
infrastructures d'énergie
le bruit d'une autre en plein mais on ne
se plaint pas
on ne juge pas il y a une compare pas et
qui à la vie plus facile
votre bien-être et les produits
de votre sécurité nationale le résultat
de votre lutte pour l'indépendance et
vos nombreuses victoires nous les
Ukrainiens
vont aussi passer par notre guerre des
indépendance vers la liberté avec
dignité et réussite
[Applaudissements]
nous allons fêter Noël
fêter Noël et même s'il y a pas de
courant on aura la lumière de notre foi
en nous-même
ne sera pas éteint
[Applaudissements]
on fera de notre mieux nous protéger si
nous attaques avec les drones iraniennes
et notre peuples doivent aller dans les
abris anti le veille de Noël on va
s'asseoir comme à la table et ce
congratuler et elle n'a pas besoin
on ne va pas avoir tous nos vœux
réalisés parce qu'on sait que nous tous
mille millions nous sommes souhaitent la
même chose c'est la victoire et
seulement la victoire c'est tout ce que
nous souhaitons
[Applaudissements]
nous avons déjà bâti un Ukraine forte
avec des gens forts un armée fort des
institutions fortes avec vous à la
développer des garanties de sécurité
pour notre pays et pour l'Europe et le
monde avec vous aussi avec vous
nous allons
mettre en place tous ceux qui vont
en valeur mettre à leur place on va
mettre Poutine à sa place ce sera la
base pour protéger la démocratie au sein
de l'Europe et dans le monde entier
maintenant
je vous remercier vous remercier à tous
je pense que chaque famille américaine
qui chérit la chaleur de foyer et qui
souhaite le même chaleur à tout le monde
je pense que le Président je le remercie
et tous les corps au Sénat et le champ
de représentant de votre assistance est
disponibilité
vos villes et vous citoyens qui ont
soutenu le crâne cette année qui n'ont
qui qui ont souhaité le bienvenu aux
Ukrainiens qui ont secoué notre drapeau
national qui agisse pour nous aider en
vous remerciez à vous tous de tout le
monde qui se trouve sur le front
de la part de chacun qui travaille et
qui œuvre pour la victoire je me tiens
devant vous aujourd'hui je me souviens
des guerres du président Franklin de
Roswell
ça vaut la peine d'y réfléchir en ce
moment même le peuple américain
dans leurs forces
va nous mener vers une victoire absolue
le peuple ukrainien va aussi gagner leur
guerre à leur tour absolument
[Applaudissements]
je sais que tout dépend de nous sur les
forces armées eugéniennes
mais beaucoup dépend du monde tellement
dans le monde dépend de vous
m'ont donné un drapeau
le drapeau de bataille le bataille de ce
qui défendent l'Ukraine et l'Europe et
le monde au cours de leur vie ils m'ont
demandé d'apporter de vous apporter ce
drapeau au Congrès américain aux membres
de le chanteur besanteur et des
sénateurs dont les décisions peuvent
sauver des millions de personnes
donc que ces décisions soient prises que
ce drapeau reste avec vous monsieur et
dames ce drapeau c'est le symbole de
notre victoire dans cette guerre
nous tenons luttons et nous allons
gagner parce que nous sommes unis
l'Ukraine l'Amérique et le monde libre
dans son entièreté
c'est inscrit à la Chambre des
représentants
par les soldats du front
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que Dieu protège notre troupes chez nos
citoyens que Dieu bénis les États-Unis
pour toujours joyeux Noël et une bonne
nouvelle année victorieuse
voilà pour cette adresse du président
ukrainien devant les élus du Congrès
américain volodimir Zelenski qui conclut
sa journée de visite historique aux
États-Unis par cette déclaration
solennelle devant les législateurs
américains et cette image forte de cet
échange vous le voyez le président
ukrainien qui est brandit ses étoiles et
qui vient de donner un drapeau
ukrainien sign
par des combattants
Ukrainiens un drapeau qui le confie donc
à la
présidente de la Chambre des
Représentants Nancy Pelosi